[Música]
en esta emisión de noticias de france 24
el presidente de estados unidos joe
biden se apega a la fecha límite del 31
de agosto para culminar el retiro de
tropas colaboradores ciudadanos y
diplomáticos
byd en reiteró que existen amenazas
terroristas y que la salida
estadounidense dependerá de la
cooperación por parte del grupo talibán
la corte suprema de eeuu rechazó la
petición de la administración by de de
bloquear la reinstauración de la
política conocida como quédate en mexico
bajo esta normativa que entró en vigor
en 2019 durante la era trump los
solicitantes de asilo son regresados a
méxico a esperar durante su proceso en
las cortes de inmigración
murió a los 80 años en un hospital de
londres el baterista de los rolling
stones o charlie watts una de las
grandes leyendas del rock and roll watts
quien había anunciado que no
participaría en la gira por eeuu
prevista para septiembre falleció
pacíficamente y rodeado de su familia
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález tuvo lugar la cumbre virtual de
urgencias de los líderes mundiales del
g7 alemania canadá estados unidos japón
italia francia y el reino unido-
discutieron sobre la situación en
afganistán y la salida total de las
tropas internacionales del país a más
tardar el próximo 31 de agosto tal y
como lo indicó el presidente de eeuu joe
biden el mandatario estadounidense
también insistió en que persisten las
amenazas de organizaciones terroristas
contra las tropas extranjeras y los
ciudadanos afganos como la organización
hay 6
un g7 de emergencia dedicado enteramente
a afganistán reunidos en una cumbre
virtual bajo la presidencia de reino
unido- las siete grandes potencias
occidentales eeuu canadá japón alemania
francia italia y reino unido buscaron
acordar un enfoque común para gestionar
las evacuaciones en curso washington
planea mantener la fecha de finalización
de sus operaciones militares y
evacuaciones para el 31 de agosto así lo
confirmó el presidente yo waiting
ahora mismo estamos en un punto de
completar las evacuaciones para el 31 de
agosto cuanto antes terminemos mejor
16 mis soldados estadounidenses están
ayudando actualmente para evacuar a los
ciudadanos estadounidenses y afganos que
se consideran en peligro en el país esto
es mientras se asegura el aeropuerto de
kabul para permitir que otros países
realicen sus propias operaciones de
evacuación varios países entre ellos
francia y reino unido han manifestado su
deseo de que se amplíe el plazo del 31
de agosto pero finalmente no se acordó
ninguna prórroga
walking away y la condición número uno
que ponemos como g7 es que los talibanes
se deben garantizar el paso seguro de
todos aquellos que quieran abandonar el
país hasta el final hasta el 31 de
agosto e incluso más allá 6
el grupo talibán no lo ve así unas horas
más tarde el portavoz se pronunció en
sentido contrario pidiendo eeuu que
nueva cuenta a los afganos más
cualificados no hay que animar a
nuestros expertos afganos ingenieros
médicos analistas ya los que se han
formado aquí a que se vayan este país
necesita sus habilidades no deben ser
evacuados a países extranjeros hasta
otros temas para el g7 definir una hoja
de ruta sobre cómo relacionarse con los
extremistas
el elíseo pide que rompan completamente
los vínculos entre los nuevos amos de
kabul y las organizaciones terroristas
añadiendo que se les juzgará por los
actos y no por los anuncios en cuanto a
la defensa de los derechos humanos de
los derechos de la mujer en particular
la corte suprema de eeuu rechazó la
petición de la administración by then de
bloquear la reinstauración de la
política conocida como quédate en mexico
una normativa del gobierno trump que
obligaba a los solicitantes de asilo a
permanecer en méxico durante el trámite
previamente cristóbal vázquez desde
washington nos dio más detalles sobre
este tema
pues esta fue una promesa de campaña que
el presidente de bailín hizo y que no
cumple y no cumple además en medio de un
contexto bastante agitado porque las
encuestas pues las tiene muy bajas
precisamente por lo que está pasando en
afganistán le doy una cifra cerca de 70
mil personas que estaban aplicando asilo
a través de la frontera entre méxico y
eeuu pues han tenido que regresar a
méxico y esperar allá la decisión de
asilo así que pues serán decenas de
miles de personas malas que se vean
afectadas y pues lo que están diciendo
los demócratas es que lastimosamente
estas personas pues no van a poder
seguir esperando en méxico van a tener
que regresar a sus países a las amenazas
precisamente de las que estaban
escapando en sus países sin embargo los
republicanos pues están argumentando que
esto es una muy buena decisión la están
celebrando porque pues dicen que haber
acabado con esta política pues era
simplemente un incentivo para que muchas
más personas a través de la frontera
entre méxico y eeuu
llegarán a eeuu de forma ilegal así que
pues una victoria para los republicanos
para donald trump y una derrota para los
demócratas
en brasilia unos 5.000 indígenas
aguardan la votación que tendrá lugar
mañana por parte del tribunal supremo
federal que definirá el futuro del
llamado marco temporal lo que definiría
entonces las demarcaciones de las
tierras indígenas
gabriela antúnes nos cuenta más
estamos en la más grande protesta
indígena de la historia del país son 5
mil indígenas y un campamento
viniendo de 117 pueblos distintos a las
pérez de la madre de los juicios
indígenas mañana el supremo tribunal
general decide la causa de los choques
algo que puedes describir el destino de
muchos de estos indígenas porque puede
servir de precedente para sus futuros
los choc les luchan para mantener la
tierra que consiguieran después de
1988 cuando fue promulgada la
constitución
de brasil si pueden seguir con sus
tierras eso significa que no van a tener
que retroceder 30 años en lo que es la
demarcación de tierras indígenas en el
brasil
pierden el agronegocio ya tienen los
ojos puestos en la expansión de la
frontera agrícola en el país los
indígenas esperan que no sea más un
revés de los tantos reveses de los
últimos años que han sufrido en el
gobierno de jair bolsonaro o muchos
incendios en las florestas de amazónicas
muchas invasiones por parte de minerías
y otro y ganadería por ejemplo entonces
la expectativa es muy fuerte en la noche
de hoy y falleció a los 80 años de edad
una de las grandes leyendas del rock and
roll hablamos de charly what's baterista
de la icónica banda the rolling stones
su publicista confirmó que la artista
murió en un hospital de londres rodeado
de su familia marina sardenya nos cuenta
quién fue charly watch
conocido por su estilo tranquilo y
fresco charly what's por decisión propia
nunca cumplió con el estereotipo de
rockstar y sin embargo durante más de 50
años fue el corazón de una de las bandas
de rock and roll más icónicas de la
historia los rolling stones este martes
tras conocerse la noticia una oleada de
mensajes ha inundado las redes sociales
para despedir a bots sus compañeros de
escenario postearon cariñosas imágenes
en sus redes pero también los seguidores
del célebre baterista y sus colegas de
profesión
estoy muy triste de escuchar que murió
charlie watts el baterista de los stones
le envió todo el amor a su familia
esposa e hija y también mis condolencias
a los stones
[Música]
un día muy triste charlie watts era el
mejor baterista el más elegante de los
hombres y una compañía brillante mi más
sentido pésame a shirley serafina y
charlotte y por supuesto a los rolling
stones este es charlie watch llorado y
querido por todos what's nació en
londres en 1941 de niño se sintió
atraído por la música jazz comenzando a
explorar su amor por el ritmo incluso
convirtiendo un viejo banjo en un tambor
sin formación profesional el joven
charlie watch aprendió observando a los
bateristas en los clubs de jazz de la
capital británica después de tocar en
varias bandas de jazz and blues pronto
conoció a mick jagger y keith richards y
se unió a los rolling stones en 1963
pero en ese momento whats pensó que no
duraría más de una semana por el
contrario en
1965 fueron impulsados al estrellato
internacional por su estilo incendiario
de música rock and roll llegaron a tener
ocho éxitos número uno en eeuu vendieron
más de 240.000 millones de álbumes en
todo el mundo y realizaron incontables
giras mundiales tocando para sus
legiones de fans a diferencia de sus
compañeros de banda what's generalmente
se resistió a los excesos de fama y se
alejó del centro de atención encontrando
refugio en su matrimonio con shirley and
shepard a quien conoció en 1964
[Música]
punto final en las noticias de france 24
siga con nosotros buenas noches
[Música]